l'été c'est des boissons fraîches des
gourmandises sucrées des roulades dans
l'air parmi les fleurs mais caché
derrière chacune de ces réjouissances
c'est une bestiole qui pourrait bien
vous faire passer un sale quart d'heure
fois rentré tout l'été des tc vous
aident à éviter les pièges et les
dangers qui menacent votre bien-être et
votre santé et des ses partenaires de
votre épée
elles sont comme vous elle profite de la
nature quand l'été arrive avec le soleil
donne la même couleur aux gens gentiment
oui mais voilà en cas de rencontre avec
la petite bête qui piquent c'est souvent
la grosse bête tu pleures on va trouver
des solutions
aujourd'hui on va se concentrer sur les
petites bêtes qu'ils volent mais avant
toute chose
faisons connaissance les abeilles alors
y'a que les femelles qui pique
mais attention le mal c'est pas le bon
ben on les appelle les faubourgs bombe à
ce qui ressemble un peu à leurs cousins
mais en fait c'est pas les mêmes les
bourdons contrairement à ce qu'on pense
et notamment parce que comme on vient de
le voir on les confond avec des abeilles
mal les gourdeau ça pique
enfin juste et femelle encore une fois
d'ailleurs c'est le cas chez tous les
autres sirènes aubeterre comme par
exemple la guette qui peut piquer
plusieurs fois contrairement à la bei
dont l'aiguillon reste planté quand elle
attaque et qui en meurent alors
remballez vos théories sexiste il n'y a
que les femelles qui fixe et parce qu'au
fur et à mesure de leur évolution leur
zovi producteurs qui sont des noms
organes fin qui tarde à prendre se sont
transformés en aiguillant et du coup
comme les mâles ne prône pas ils sont
pas d'aiguillon d'ailleurs les mâles
n'ont pas vraiment besoin de se défendre
puisqu'ils sortent assez peu mais qui
sont très occupés à leur principale
activité la reproduction
d'ailleurs deviner finement la pointe de
l'aiguillon vous connaissez peut-être
aussi le temps sympathique animal qui
n'est pas un hélicoptère mais qui pique
aussi
et devinez quoi seulement les femelles
sauf que contrairement à toutes les
précédentes elle n est pas pour se
défendre et qu'on nous vole et un peu de
sang comme les moustiques
sauf que la douleur est pas la même on
sait bien joli tout ça mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand on sait que pitié on
commence à retirer les bagues les
chaînes les bracelets les [ __ ] et
tout autre objet qui entoure le membre
piqué parce qu'il va gonfler et clarisse
de comprimés est qu après ce sera trop
tard pour l'anglais ensuite il aiguille
on est restés plantés dans la peau on
glisse quelque chose de fort en dessous
et on le fait sauter sans appuyer dessus
parce que ça risquerait de presser sur
la glande qui est restée accrochée et
qu'ils injecteraient encore plus
devenant et maintenant la solution même
si vous fumez allumé une cigarette c'est
sans doute la seule situation dans
laquelle ça va avoir un effet bénéfique
approchez-vous incandescent de l'endroit
qui a été piqué suffisamment près pour
que la chaleur soit perceptible mais pas
trop pour pas de ça brûle et attendez
quelques secondes le venant de petites
bestioles est thermolabile c'est à dire
que la chaleur line active donc ça va
soulager la douleur
alors on est d'accord que n'importe quel
autre source de chaleur fera la sphère
que ce soit un bon point accordé sans un
briquet un allume cigare un sèche
cheveux pour un chanteur de charme
si vous faite piquer en pleine nature
vous avez quand même pas mal plus de
chance de trouver quelqu'un qui fume que
quelqu'un qui se fait un brushing ou qui
dans ce rugby vous pouvez ensuite
nettoyé la piqûre avec un antiseptique
parce que ces petites bestioles ont la
fâcheuse habitude de tremper leur dard
un peu n'importe où si vous voyez ce que
je veux avec le coup la cigarette la
douleur devrait avoir disparu mais si
c'est pas le cas
n'hésitez pas à prendre un an 28 en cas
de piqûre dans la bouche prévenu le samu
au 15 parce qu'à cet endroit là si ça se
met à gonfler ça va empêcher l'air de
passer quelle que soit la zone piquée
prévenait aussi le 15 en cas de
démangeaisons importantes dans tout le
corps et de difficultés respiratoires
qui sont des films de réactions
allergiques
si tout va bien vous pouvez faire un
saut chez le pharmacien en rentrant
votre petit malade et lui demander
quelque chose à mettre sur la piqûre
pour apaiser faire dégonfler et calmer
les démangeaisons pommade gel clan tuile
est essentiel il y en a pour tous les
goûts dans les jours suivants si le
thème c'est à dire le gonflement ne
disparaît pas aussi de la fièvre des
frissons apparaissent il faut consulter
un médecin pour vérifier qu'il n'ya pas
une infection
avant de se quitter et parce que rien ne
remplace la prévention deux ou trois
conseils pour éviter de se faire piquer
éviter de marcher pieds nus dans l'herbe
pour éviter de marcher sur une bestiole
en train de cultiver nous faire sa
sieste posait mettez-vous à sa place si
on vous marchez dessus pour le votre
bain de soleil et vous avez un gros
d'art vous aussi vous en servir
méfiez-vous des canettes aka le bébé du
canard à tout pour voir la fraîcheur et
le sucre ça attire tout ce petit monde
et si bêtes qu'ils entendent voir un
coup à fond de ce que vous vous êtes en
train de voir vous risquez de vous faire
piquer versez votre boisson dans un
verre et soyez du club les temps préfère
la peau mouillée
alors c'est chez vous en sortant de
l'eau quand vous vous êtes bénis pour
finir on dit aussi que les vêtements de
couleurs vives attire les films et nokia
parce qu'ils les prennent pour des
fleurs mais bon on va pas s'empêcher de
la revue soit quand même voix la dtcc
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
dans 15 jours pour une nouvelle vidéo
si la portée